what's going on guys let's talk suicide
squad
the suicide squad movie was really fun
it was a really really really good movie
here's the funny thing though
i see a lot of people out there who are
vocalizing complaints and kind of
comparing it to the marvel cinematic
universe thing
there's not really a lot of character
development going on there there's a
reason for that
if you are familiar with the suicide
squad comics you know that james gunn
nailed the movie and the reason for that
is sure rick flagg and harley quinn got
a lot of screen time and we already knew
who they were we knew that they were
basically going to make it into the end
for the rest of the cast bloodsport and
king shark and polkadot man all that
kind of stuff
we didn't really get a whole lot of
backstory there i mean we did to a
degree where we got
kind of an origin for polkadot in the
sense of like he's the result of his
mom's experimentation and some of his
brothers and sisters lived
others died he's got to spew out those
polka dots twice a day otherwise they'll
consume him alive
so we got really more explanation on his
story than we did pretty much anybody
else but you got what amounts to like
quick little explanations right amanda
waller said that bloodsport basically
put superman
in the icu with a kryptonite bullet and
then the most we get outside of that is
like
the relationship between himself and his
daughter is pretty straight right we
don't even really get an origin for king
shark
but it's one of these things where you
don't really get a whole lot going there
and there's a reason for that so the
suicide squad in dc comics is designed
to be
in effect a throwaway team and dc uses
the suicide squad for a couple of
different reasons
one is to sometimes boost the popularity
of villains that exist in the dc
landscape
because the team has really been popular
since harley quinn was put on it
which makes sense because nobody would
care about suicide squad if harley quinn
wasn't on it
or the other reason why they use it is
to get rid of villains right to write
them out here's a really good example
in recent years dc comics created a
character named punchline who was
designed to replace harley quinn
no it didn't work nobody cares so what
you'll likely see
is that punchline will be rolled over
into the suicide squad relatively soon
and then she'll die like three or four
issues after her first appearance
if not maybe 10 or so right but she'll
die within two story arcs
because dc is just writing her character
out and when she's dead you'll never see
her hear from her again
that's what they end up using it for but
the entire basis behind the suicide
squad is with the exception of harley
quinn in the comics
is designed to be a rotating roster that
the villains who are on the team
don't really matter because they're
designed to be cannon fodder
and james gunn nailed that with this
movie it's why when the movie opens up
literally the first team that you think
is a suicide squad dies
which admittedly i wish michael rooker
had more time in that film
and now that i think about it james gunn
if you see this video
i really hope we get a prequel to the
suicide squad that takes place between
the terrible one that had will smith
and this great one that you made that
basically gives us like adventures
with the first team that died in the
very beginning because i kind of want to
see that
i really want to see a movie with that
team it looked amazing right like
disconnecting man or whatever his name
is
i really want to see that but the
important thing here is that's why you
didn't really get a whole lot of
development in relation to the villains
because literally the next suicide squad
movie could open up and idris elba dies
in the first five minutes that's just
the nature of the team anybody can die
at any point in time under virtually any
circumstance they're designed to be
throwaway
having said that with regards to pretty
much everything else in the movie
it was fantastic it's exactly what i was
hoping it would be a comic book film
composed of super villains that didn't
take itself too seriously
i think the biggest issue with the first
suicide squad film is it didn't feel
like that it felt like they were trying
to make like this real
tangible amazing comic book movie that
was in line with something like the
marvel cinematic universe
and that's not really what the suicide
squad is supposed to be it's supposed to
be a movie about villains who can die at
any point in time
and who cares the story is what's
important
not really the characters and james gunn
nailed that the story was great
i am kind of shocked that they use
starro
as the main villain if i'm being honest
starro was a justice league villain
right that was like the first big thing
for the justice league
was fighting starro so i always kind of
hoped that starro would be a villain
that justice lee would face off against
having said that
starro does seem kind of goofy and kind
of silly and he is
currently in dc comics he's in a jar so
he's called jaro literally he hangs out
with batman all the time
but it's one of those things where it's
kind of like that's kind of goofy and
silly so
maybe staro really was a great fit for
the suicide squad because it worked
right it was cool
it was kind of sad at the end right when
like starro died he was like
i was just i was happy just floating in
space staring at the stars
and then humanity came along and screwed
it up i feel like that's james gunn's
just critique on humanity like hey guys
what's one thing humanity's really good
at screwing stuff up
awesome because we are we're really good
at screwing things up
but that's that's kind of the craziness
about it right you know it's the movie
was
fun it was it was enjoyable it was a
great popcorn film
i don't know that i would go and see it
again and that's really kind of
the interesting thing about it a lot of
people really determine whether or not
they consider a movie to be good
by whether or not they would go and see
it a second time i saw infinity war in
avengers in-game once that was enough
for me right i mean i was like this is
cool
not gonna go see it again so that's not
really my standard for determining
whether or not a movie is good but i
know some of you guys use that standard
so i figured i would go ahead and impart
that on you having said that for my
standard
did i have a good time was i ever bored
did i find myself yawning over the
course of the movie that's kind of my
standard
if i yawn in the movie and i'm not
really exhausted
then it's like your movie sucks and it's
boring right like the irishman i fell
asleep during that movie
twice that movie was bad it was bad and
it was boring
i'm sorry martin scorsese you peaked
with goodfellas but the important thing
here
is that with a suicide squad film it was
great it was fun it was enjoyable right
it's one of those movies you can just
kind of go
and just have a good time just watch
some crazy stuff happen i did love the
hyper violence
that's one of the things that i really
did enjoy i feel like there wasn't
really enough
like dark humor comedic like hyper
violence
like there was you know in in the first
movie i mean the first movie sure there
was violence but it was more like
like typical violence right like
standard comic book violence right like
i mean i will say that like like was it
deadshot like shooting up all those
those zombie monster things that was
like the only good part of the whole
movie literally
you guys you guys agree i've seen how
many views that video has on youtube
everybody loves that scene right it's
one of the coolest scenes nobody
cares about any of the other scenes in
that movie but the cool thing is is with
this film it's just it's enjoyable it's
good right so
if what you're looking for is something
that doesn't feel like the marvel
cinematic universe in the sense that
it doesn't feel a cookie cutter
formulaic it's kind of a breakaway
small hints of guardians of the galaxy
in there chris pratt did have a cameo i
wonder if you guys spotted it
uh small little things like that in
there it's good it's it's just
it's separate and it's unique and it's
interesting it's fun
and i really believe that james gunn's
portrayal of the suicide squad in this
movie is almost kind of like his
guardians of the galaxy thing right like
i can take a ridiculously obscure team
that you didn't even know existed until
we announced the movie and i bet i can
turn it into like a huge hit again
that's the big difference
the entire guardians of the galaxy film
got a lot of character development
suicide squad didn't right it was more
about the story so you probably walk
away
more curious about starro or any or
maybe probably king shark king shark was
the best character in the whole movie
let's all just
admit that but like you know you might
walk away with more of a curiosity about
starro and king shark than anybody else
but the story is what you likely
remember the most because
that's the main emphasis of suicide
squad so i i love that right i mean i
think that this movie shows
that dc has great characters they've got
great characters that you can do a lot
of stuff with their characters
all you need is a competent director all
you need is somebody who can come along
and say hey
i can make great movies with these
characters right and you're not gonna
have to get a special cut in order for
that to happen so with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace